[Musik]
fast ein Jahr Krieg und kein Ende in
Sicht Berlin hat es gewählt aber bleibt
trotzdem die Musik alles beim Alten und
wir sprechen über den nächsten
gez-skandal spannende Themen heute hier
bei 8:15 Uhr und ich freue mich auf
diese Gäste für Kinderschützer und
mobbingexperte Carsten Stahl ist klar
wir brauchen endlich härtere Strafen
braucht nächste wahlpanel in Berlin rund
450 Wahlbriefe wurden nicht mitgezählt
Bild politik-chef Jan Schäfer kann nur
noch einen Kopfschütteln auch darüber
dass die alte Koalition trotz massiver
Verluste weitere regieren will
Journalist Thomas Fastner
Aktivisten an die Seite und sagt der
Klimawandel der schreitet voran und die
Politik müsste endlich Gegenstände alle
reden über das friedensmanifest von
Alice Schwarzer und Sarah Wagenknecht
und Journalist Julian Marius schüttet
den Kopf Putin verstehen nur Herze
dieses Manifest sei
weil der nächste Skandal bei den
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen wie fast immer
geht es ums Geld denn es sind Beträge
die hätte wohl jeder der fleißig
arbeitet geht gerne auf dem Konto
432.000 Euro fürs nichts tun und eine
Rente von 9.000 Euro ja dieses lukrative
Abfindungspaket bekommt rbb
Programmdirektor Jan Schulze Kellinghaus
der vorzeitig seinen Sessel räumt das
sind Informationen von unseren Kollegen
von Business Insider ja Normalsterbliche
die können von Solingen natürlich nur
träumen sie sind es aber die solche
Abfindungen und Pensionen mit ihrem
Rundfunkbeitrag finanzieren Herr Stahl
finden Sie dass der Rundfunkbeitrag
ihren funkbeitrag trotzdem gut angelegt
ist
garantiert nicht ich meine der Mann hat
sicherlich seine Leistung erbracht aber
steht die Leistung zu dem was wir dafür
bezahlen müssen und vor allen Dingen bei
denen der ganzen Kritik und die ganzen
Skandalen die hier schon beim rbb
gewesen sind ist das glaube ich das
falsche Signal und vor allen Dingen wenn
ich immer wieder denke wir sollen die
Gürtel irgendeiner schneiden und dann
gibt's so eine Abfindung ich meine ja
wie heißt immer so die oberen 10.000
davon haben wir 700 und ein paar 30 im
Bundestag die genauso abgehoben sind ich
denke man sollte vielleicht mal
überlegen ob diese Gebühren nicht anders
einzusetzen sind vor allem für auch
Probleme die wir in unserem Land haben
oder ja dann müssen ja andere auch
private Sender müssen ja auch sich
selbst ihr Geld herbeizaubern vielleicht
sollten die das auch mal aber
wir werden sehen was die Zukunft bringt
denn das ist definitiv das falsche
Signal und ich als Bürger kann schon
sagen auch über das was ich teilweise da
sehe was der öffentliche Rundfunk zeigt
besonders in den letzten zweieinhalb
Jahren der Pandemie würde ich sagen ich
würde eigentlich schon bald sagen wir
zahlen mal nicht mal gucken was passiert
wegsperren können Sie uns alle nicht
über die Zahlen reden schauen Sie noch
öffentlich-rechtliche
Tradition
Blick in die deutsche Gesellschaft oder
was Sie über sich selber denkt ich
schaue sonst überhaupt nichts anderes
und mehr und mehr erwische ich mich
darüber dass ich eine Tatort eine
Viertelstunde später in der Mediathek
schaue weil es um 20:15 Uhr auch nicht
mehr schaffe also das lineare Fernsehen
könnte für mich auch nicht existieren
ist gerade gesagt gerade die
Pensionslasten die verschlingenden ganz
ordentlichen Batzen jetzt gibt's neues
Projekt bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen
man will Social Media aktiver werden
also so etwas wie Twitter und Facebook
machen ist das denn für sie eine gute
Entwicklung
möchte tatsächlich ein Facebook eine Art
Twitter alternative etablieren das ist
ungefähr so wie wenn Opel versucht einen
Porsche zu bauen also unglaublich was
für eine Anmaßung dass ein Unternehmen
ein Staatsunternehmen in
Anführungszeichen es ist in von der
Struktur her ähnlich tatsächlich in der
Lage sein möchte zu wissen was Ihre
Mitarbeiter bzw ihre Kunden wollen und
das können sie gar nicht weil es findet
der Marktpreis es fehlt überhaupt der
Austausch mit den entsprechenden
Nutzern von daher ja ein weiteres
Milliardengrab herzlichen Glückwunsch
rein sagen also ich höre schon in dieser
Runde wird kein gutes Zeugnis
ausgestellt Jan wie siehst du das ganze
muss man da so wie kassenstall das auch
angedeutet hat irgendwann mal wirklich
über eine radikale Reform nachdenken es
gibt immer mehr die sagen brauche ich
eigentlich gar nicht mehr
öffentlich-rechtliche absolut richtig
richtig
gesagt haben ja fast behindert zu der
Frage Tatort ein Spiegel der
Gesellschaft genau das ist glaube ich
nämlich nicht abgesehen davon dass da
dauernd jemand ermordet wird aber wenn
wir mal anschauen wie Unternehmer
beispielsweise im Tatort dargestellt
werden dann werden sie zu großen Teilen
immer
negativ dargestellt ist immer der böse
Unternehmer der irgendjemand böse möchte
und hinterlistig ist und rumtrickst was
die Drehbuchautoren über die
Gesellschaft
genau richtig glaube ich auch aber da
sind wir auch schon bei der Frage und
das hat Herr Steuer auch gerade gesagt
also ist es das Geld wert was wir dort
investieren und da glaube ich gibt es
eine so große
Medienvielfalt in diesem Land das
möglicherweise ein
öffentlich-rechtlicher Sender absolut
ausreichend wäre und dann glaube ich ist
ja die Aufgabe des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Senders auch
ausgewogen zu berichten und wenn man
sich dort die Talkshows anschaut und wir
haben Jungs ja eine Umfrage von
mediathenow auch gesehen wie berichtet
wird beispielsweise über Politiker da
muss man sagen dann fehlt diese
Ausgewogenheit vollkommen gibt diese
Auswertung von Januar 2021 bis dezember
2022 und wunder wunder Marlo 3er Chefin
Funk Rates kommt in der
Berichterstattung gut weg nur gute
Beiträge oder ausgewogene Beiträge wir
erinnern aber es gab eine große
Flutkatastrophe in diesem Zeitraum und
offensichtlich hat Manu Dreyer aus sich
zumindest auch das ZDF und der ARD so
gut wie alles richtig gemacht und das
widerspricht den Tatsachen dass sie sich
beispielsweise in der Flut nach der
irgendwann noch verabschiedet hat gesagt
hat ich bin jetzt nicht mehr zu
erreichen und dann erst morgen früh
wieder widerspricht den Tatsachen Armin
Laschet ist über die Dinge die passiert
sind in der Flugzeit dann so gestolpert
dass er nicht mehr Kanzler werden konnte
und das ZDF berichtet also über Malu
Dreyer nur positiv maximal neutral in
denen heute Nachrichten das kann nicht
wahr sein da sieht man auch dass es
einen gewissen politischen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Filz gibt und den
muss man nicht finanzieren hier an
diesem Tisch nicht unbedingt Fans werden
das jetzt gesprochen eine radikale
Reform kassenstall was wäre das nur noch
ein öffentlich-rechtlicher Sender oder
brauchen wir die gar nicht mehr oder
zumindest die Gebühren nicht mehr
privatisieren was könnte man tun also
grundsätzlich lassen wir es doch die
Bürger entscheiden wenn ich das gerne
abonnieren möchte dann zahle ich dafür
und wenn nicht dann gibt's das nicht ich
meine müssen sie genauso sich in der
Marktwirtschaft zu Recht finden wie alle
anderen sie haben sie haben eine Hoheit
und ist schon seit Jahren wird in das
Geld hinten reingesteckt aber das was
sie berichten spiegelt nicht mehr das
wirklich wieder was der Bürger ist also
sie sind vollkommen Fans
wie im Bundestag und ich sehe da sehr
viele Parallelen und linkes Auge und
grünes Auge blind auch da sehe ich viele
Parallelen also lassen wir doch die
Bürger entscheiden die sollten sowieso
viel mehr Entscheidungsrecht haben und
dann werden wir da mal sehen wie viel
sie sich noch ein Sohn Pension leisten
können ich denke das wird dann rapide
herabgesetzt an diese Frage des
Sprechens des Ständer sprechen also wir
erleben jetzt dass Politiker
beispielsweise Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sagen und aber in den sozialen Medien
das ZDF selbst immer ein gender Stern
dazu fügt beispielsweise also da werden
Dinge auch noch falsch wirklich falsch
berichtet und sie haben es ja vollkommen
richtig gesagt so spricht die große
Mehrheit spricht nicht so und wenn die
große mehr aber so sprechen soll dann
muss man einfach den Bürger entscheiden
lassen wir stellen das ab wir wollen
nicht so Bescheid werden auch nicht so
erzogen werden verdient euer Geld am
besten selbst und dann wird man sehen
wie wir dann in den Nachrichten
angesprochen werden ob als BürgerInnen
oder als Bürger einfach nur und für sie
müsste dann nur noch der Tatort mein
Leben ist das alles was sie noch wollen
oder das nicht also ich nehme das jetzt
mal nicht als ich als Konsument ist die
große Gefahr ist dass das
öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen gerade
Riesenfehler macht und zwar den Fehler
macht nicht zu sehen dass hier eine
unglaublich teure zwangssubventionierte
Institution mitten im Fokus einer
grundsätzlich kritisch bestimmten
bestimmten Öffentlichkeit steht es geht
ja nicht nur um das Fernsehen um die
Schulen es geht um die öffentlichen
Toiletten es geht um die Bahn es geht um
den um die Flughäfen etc und
von einer unterschwellige Empörung macht
sich breit und immer breit und zwar auch
weit außerhalb der AFD oder der Linken
ja und das die ARD und das ZDF also die
öffentlich rechtlichen Sender stehen
gewissermaßen die werden den Prügel
Knaben abgeben es wird so weit kommen
und die lassen es auch soweit kommen
tombur oder der Chef der der das DDR hat
ja im letzten Jahr im Prinzip schon mal
einen Ansatz gemacht
sechs Monate her oder so das versandet
sie das ist eine Institution die sich so
stark fest fühlt wie die SED-Spitze 1989
unbedingt Schritte brutale Schritte die
irgendein Prozess muss eingeleitet
werden von Trial and Error man wird nie
kein Mensch keine Partei wird mit einem
Wurf jetzt den idealen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk der
Zukunft haben wir haben 60 Jahre Stau
praktisch in dem ganzen oder 30 Jahre
auf jeden Fall Stau in dem drin
Zusammenlegung ARD ZDF einfach manches
muss man erst einmal kaputt schlagen
damit wieder was neues zusammenwachsen
kann ich würde es wirklich nicht sagen
nur noch Tatort ja aber wir müssen sehen
muss ein öffentlich rechtlich bezahlte
Rundfunk den den ganzen Trend zum Trash
TV mitgehen ich habe übrigens immer was
vergessen achte sich sehr gerne ja diese
deutsche französische gut das hat ein
gewisses hinterlegt Realis Niveau und so
also da bin ich jetzt schon noch mehr
als beim Tatort engagiert aber der der
ganze Trash TV muss muss die Konkurrenz
mit den privaten so laufen ähm obwohl
man einseitig finanzierte diese Fragen
müssen die nur gestellt werden sondern
die müssen einfach mal auch man muss
einfach mal der nordischen Knoten wir
sind an einem Punkt wo der Knoten nicht
mehr nicht mehr
befreit oder geöffnet werden kann
sondern wer wirklich durchgeschlagen
werden muss was bedeutet das ja bloß
dann auch für Sport und Unterhaltung
muss es so etwas gar nicht geben
Gebühren finanziert braucht man wirklich
nur noch einen Sender wie stehen sie
sich
wozu denn Sport ich bin sehr
begeisterter oder was mit ein bisschen
noch Fußballfan heute spielt Bayern
München das läuft auf Amazon Prime
glaube ich wenn ich recht informiert bin
gut das kann man machen das kann man
dann zahlen 90 € im Jahr ich mache
übrigens keine Werbung keine Sorge aber
nein nein es ist völlig unsinnig und
unnötig das Unterhaltung mit finanziert
wird weil man muss das man muss das
nicht man darf das nicht vergessen wenn
man die Gebühren nicht zahlt folgt
Zwangsgeld und zwangsaft das heißt die
fängnis es gab Leute die schon im
Gefängnis waren deswegen weil sie nicht
in aller Freundschaft und Tatort mit
finanzieren wollten und das muss man
sich doch wirklich mal auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen deswegen nein weg damit
zerschlagen
ich glaube Kinder in unserem Land frei
rum die Kinder missbraucht haben da sind
wir schon gleich bei ihrem Thema ganz
wichtiges Thema über das war heute Abend
auch sprechen wollen noch einmal zurück
auch Jan zu diesem zahlen also
gleichzeitig will viele sind sie hier am
Tisch eigentlich sagen also muss ich
endlich was tun gleichzeitig schaut man
sich an über 400.000 Euro kriegt man
dann quasi fürs nichts tun für die
Verabschiedung aus dem Job 9000 9000 €
Rente dafür kann man nur träumen was ist
das auch für ein Signal
veröffentlich sind ganz ganz viele Dinge
auseinandergelaufen und ähm das Problem
was man das sie dort sehen ist das eine
ganz ganz enge Verknüpfung gibt zwischen
dem Journalismus und dem Politikern die
einen also Journalisten sollen in
gewisser Weise kam ich möchte nicht
sagen überwachen aber immer wieder
überprüfen ist das was du tust
eigentlich richtig umgekehrt sehen wir
es ja dass in diesen Rundfunkgeräten
ganz ganz viele Politiker sitzen die
umgekehrt also die Journalisten
überwachen überprüfen sollen und das
kann ja nicht funktionieren also wenn
man sich gegenseitig kontrollieren soll
gibt es Automat Mensch ein System von
Abhängigkeiten und das ist hat noch nie
funktioniert und das genau sehen wir
jetzt halt auch dort und vielleicht noch
ein Punkt um das einmal nur klar zu
machen wir sind ja Journalisten und
natürlich ist Jobabbau für jeden den
erfährt eine ganz ganz blöde Sache und
das glaube ich sei einmal dahin gesagt
auch weil es viele tolle Kollegen auch
bei den öffentlichen rechtlichen gibt
aber was mir immer wieder auffällt ist
wenn wir zu Pressekonferenzen gehen
beispielsweise oder zu anderen
Veranstaltungen dann sehe ich immer ganz
ganz viele verschiedene Mikrofone
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunkanstalt
und da ist ja schon die Frage warum geht
er nicht eine Person hin und bedient die
restlichen Rundfunkanstalten mit warum
muss der Radio Bremen der seinische
Rundfunk der Bayerische Rundfunk der
Hessische Rundfunk und im Zweifel noch
der Norddeutsche Rundfunk eigentlich
jeweils eine Person hinschicken das kann
eine Person machen einfach Mikro hin
eine Kamera im Zweifel noch aufstellen
und dann bedient man mit einer einzigen
persona mit zweien die ganze ganze
Landschaft dafür braucht man nicht zehn
zwölf 14 18 Leute wir kommen direkt zu
deinem Thema denn wir sprechen hier auch
über Vertrauen das hat Carsten Stahl
auch eben gerade angesprochen und also
immer mehr Menschen verlieren natürlich
aufgrund dieser Entwicklung auch das
Vertrauen in die Berichterstattung das
Vertrauen wird auch verloren wenn wir
jetzt auf die Wahl in der Hauptstadt
blicken Jan dort hat die CDU ein Sieg
hingelegt und jetzt aber kann man
befürchten dass das eigentlich so
weitergeht wie zuvor wie immer wie
Wiederholungswahl könnte vielleicht
sogar zu einer Wiederholung der
Wiederholung kommen es ist dein Thema
wir da der Wähler Wille nicht erfüllt
und was könnte das für Konsequenzen
haben also was wir in Berlin erleben das
ist ja eine Horror-Show kann man sagen
eine horror-wahl die in 20 21
stattgefunden hat und die jetzt
nachgeholt wurde und wir sehen jetzt
eine politische Horrorshow hätten daran
es gibt einen rot grünes Bündnis in
Berlin das und zwar flächendeckend
sowohl SPD wie auch Linksparteien ein
kleines bisschen auch die Grünen
verloren hat alle drei Parteien haben
verloren und sind trotzdem der Meinung
mit diesem loser Bündnis diese Stadt
weiter regieren zu können da gibts
verständliche Gründe warum Franziska
gefallen mit dem schlechtesten Ergebnis
aller Zeiten für die SPD sich krampfhaft
an die Macht klammert sie hat die Angst
dass sie danach politisch komplett
erledigt ist und das mit 44 Jahren aber
das hilft der Stadt natürlich nicht die
dringend einen Neuanfang braucht und man
kann weder Willen wen wir ihn hier
gesehen haben 28% für die CDU ja nicht
einfach ignorieren erinnern wir uns
einmal an den Wahlamt 2021 die
Bundestagswahl 26 September danach
standen vor allem die spd-chefs
Generalsekretär auch Olaf Scholz auch
und haben gesagt Mensch wir liegen doch
knapp vor der Union damals waren es 1,5%
Punkte wir SPD haben den
Regierungsauftrag und nicht der
Zweitplatzierte die Union jetzt ist das
Ganze umgekehrt die CDU liegt 10% Punkte
vor der Zweitplatzierten SPD und wunder
wunder die SPD als Zweitplatzierte
sachlich ja die CDU die hat ein
spalterischen Wahlkampf geführt er hat
deswegen gar keine Recht eine Regierung
zu bilden so kann man die Tatsache nicht
verdrehen und wer das tut der spielt mit
der Glaubwürdigkeit der Politik der
spielt auch mit der Glaubwürdigkeit
dieses demokratischen Systems die sonst
sehr sehr zurückhaltende FAZ spricht
auch von Heuchelei was hier in Berlin
bisher passiert ist ist ein Skandal und
ich wette trotzdem die CDU wird am Ende
die Regierung stellen dann vielleicht in
der großen Koalition würde das dann
etwas in Berlin verändern also ich
glaube was diese Stadt braucht ist ein
politischer Neuanfang und für das
Gegenteil von Neuanfang steht eine
Weiterführung der Rot-Rot grünen
Koalition diese Stadt wird seit 21
Jahren unter SPD-Führung regiert die
meiste Zeit regierte die Linkspartei die
SED er mit ganz klar SED Erben es gab
auch ein Nachruf auf den Verstorbenen
SED Bonzen Hans Motor also das ist eine
ganz klare SED-Nachfolgepartei und diese
beiden haben zusammen zum Teil auch mit
den Grünen fünf Jahre lang auch mit der
CDU diese Geschicke der Stadt bestimmt
und dafür gesorgt dass diese Stadt eine
bürgerfeindliche Bürokratie hat dass die
Stadt nur spitze ist wenn es um
Kriminalität geht um Staatsschulden und
um stützeempfänger aber bei vielen
anderen Dingen komplett hinterher hängt
im Bundestrend auch was das Thema
Schulsystem angeht was das Thema Verkehr
angeht also Berlin ist wirklich ein
Schlusslicht in vielen Dingen nur da wo
es negativ ist ein
Spitze und von daher braucht die Stadt
einen neuen Anfang und natürlich ist es
so mit einem neuen Regierungschef ob
einem der passt oder nicht wird diese
Stadt anders regiert werden ohne Frage
wenn wir Carsten Stahl auf diese Karte
hier schauen die ich einmal auch in die
Kamera halten möchte da sieht man sehr
viel schwarz und einen grünen Kern kein
einziges direkt Mandat hat die SPD
gewonnen möchte jetzt aber weitergehen
sie sind wahrscheinlich der Berliner
kann man sagen
sie das auch die SPD damit nicht auch
ihre eigene stammvilla schafft vergrault
also die die eigentlich auch sonst die
SPD gewählt haben Arbeiter
Krankenschwester also gibt's da
überhaupt noch einen Zugang ich glaube
die haben vollkommen die Realität zu den
Bürgern verloren und auch zu ihrem
wahlpublikum im Endeffekt sind sie so
links und grün gesteuert dass sie nur
noch Marionetten sind sind und dass ich
die Liebe Franziska Giffey da jetzt
hinstellt und mit den Füßen auftreten
und sagt ich bleibe aber jetzt hier ist
wie so ein Bock jetzt Kind was einfach
nicht akzeptieren will dass man verloren
hat sie wurden abgestraft abgemahnt und
wie weit das jetzt die CDU verändern
kann verbessern kann weiß man nicht aber
die Bürger haben ganz klar signalisiert
wir wollen das so nicht so und das ist
auch eine ganz klare Warnung Richtung
Bundesregierung und ampelregierung das
hier ist ein Signal ihr habt versagt und
wir vertrauen und euch nicht mehr und
wenn man das jetzt tut dann macht man so
weiter wie vorher nur mal nebenbei
marsolute ich und noch ein paar andere
haben für die Neuwahlen gesorgt das war
wieder der AFD das war auch nicht die
CDU sondern wir waren das wir haben in
der Scheiße Gebühr man wollte es sogar
verhindern es gab Neuwahlen wir haben
für die Demokratie eingestanden damit
sich Wasser verändert das hier ist ein
Schlag ins Gesicht der Demokratie und
der Bürger die gewählt haben und wenn
Frau gifheim bisschen Rückgrat hat dann
würde sie die Konsequenzen ziehen und
sagen okay dann gehe ich halt mit denen
zusammen die gewonnen haben
und trete zurück in meiner Position und
dann muss sie sich halt aus zweiter
Reihe beweisen und behaupten es reicht
halt nicht einfach nur die Kamera zu
grinsen und immer mal wieder eine rote
Jacke an zu haben wir brauchen Macher
und ob Kai das ist oder nicht ich kenne
ihn persönlich kenne viele von der CDU
persönlich das muss auch beweisen aber
Fakt ist dieses Erbe was er hier
übernimmt oder was überhaupt genommen
wird ist der Katastrophe das wurde hier
gerade gesagt Katastrophe und nur weil
wir dabei sind wir haben in dieser SPD
Regierung ja geführt von 1974 bis ins
Jahr 2004 ein kennt der Experiment
gehabt da wurden Kinder in die Hände von
Pädophilen gegeben bis heute hat diese
Regierung diese führen dass ich
aufgearbeitet und hat sogar Akten die
wichtigsten Sachen gestellt so reagiert
so reagiert man in Berlin das hat nichts
mit Demokratie zu tun und schon gar
nichts mit Bürger Nähe oder
Kinderfreundlichkeit das werden wir
gleich vertiefen auch noch mal das Thema
Kinderschutz das ist ihr Herzens Thema
deswegen sind sie auch heute hier der
werden wir gleich noch mal ganz intensiv
auch drüber sprechen
Sie auf diese Wahl man muss jetzt fast
befürchten dass die die Wiederholung der
Wiederholung eventuell droht heute kam
raus 450 stimmende Briefwahl wurde
überhaupt nicht gezählt muss man jetzt
auch noch mal schauen glauben sie bald
gehen wir schon wieder zu uns das glaube
ich nicht aber ihr beide Optimismus
beeindruckt mich ja schon ja ich weiß
nicht ob ich da so ganz mit kann ja das
jetzt also irgendwie eine gewende
Stimmung oder umbruchstimmung da ist
immer da haben nur 63% gewählt also für
mich sind die nicht Wähler immer
diejenigen die sagen so wie es ist läuft
ja ja von denen die gewählt haben haben
fast fast
50%. das gewählt was sie bisher hatten
ja also praktisch wenn wir die die rot
rot grün gewählt haben plus die nicht
wieder zusammen sind dann habe ich meine
erste Reaktion war wenn die Leute den
Schilddrüse die leben wollen sondern
verdient ja ich lebe ja auch in Berlin
man kann ja hier leben ja weil es ist ja
nicht so dass dass man wegziehen muss
man wird ich wünsche mir definitiv ein
anderes Berlin ich wünsche mir definitiv
eine andere Hauptstadt Politik definitiv
eine andere Regierung aber ich sehe
überhaupt nicht warum diejenigen die
jetzt an der Regierung sind nicht
einfach sagen können wo ist denn der
Gegenwind und dann kommt natürlich noch
ein zu der der Kai Wegner ich kenne die
nicht und habe auch keinen Vorteil aber
er ist natürlich auch keiner also ich
will mal so sagen ich muss immer
überlegen wie der heißt ja also keiner
der das Charisma hat der jetzt so aus
dem Hintergrund mitreißt dass man das
alle sagen es gibt doch mal dem die
Chance ja gut
ist ja trotzdem glaube ich ähm weil sie
das gerade sagt natürlich gibt es eine
linke mehr das ist vollkommen richtig
man kann den Fehler wählen ähm
ignorieren man kann nicht ignorieren im
Prinzip ist es vollkommen richtig zu
sagen wir haben hier eine linke mehr wir
machen das ich erinner aber gerade die
Sozialdemokraten an ihre Aussagen vom
Wahlamt 2021 und da hat sich Olaf Scholz
hingestellt und mit den Worten für eine
Ampelkoalition geworden das wären die
drei Parteien die bei der Wahl zugelegt
hätten die CDU vollkommen zu Recht hatte
in dem Fall verloren jetzt kann ich mich
aber nicht anderthalb oder noch nicht
mal anderthalb Jahre später ja
hinstellen als Spitzen der
Sozialdemokratie und das was ich vor 17
Monaten gesagt habe einfach wieder
umbringen ich kann es natürlich machen
ist vollkommen richtig aber was würde
ein rot-rot-grünes Bündnis in der
Situation in der Stimmungslage der Stadt
mit dem Ergebnis auch der CDU den
eigentlich sein ein totales loser
Bündnis und wir wissen was Medusa
Bündnisse passiert nehmen wir mal das
Thema wir haben sie lügilanti genannt
bei Bild Andrea YT die die ein Loser
Bündnis geschmiedet hat damals in Hessen
und am Ende gestolpert ist nicht mal
nicht mal die Wahl zumindest der
Präsidentin gewonnen hat man kann das so
machen ohne Frage man kann aber auch
dafür sorgen dass der Unmut in dieser
Stadt noch viel größer wird dann würde
ich sagen macht auf jeden Fall rot rot
grün dann habt ihr den Bürger sie haben
es ja auch gerade den Bürger gesehen
richtig verstanden oder man sagt wir
versuchen es mit der stärksten Partei
was eigentlich demokratische
geflogenheit in diesem Land ist bis auf
einige Ausnahmen macht man das so und
dann müssen sich die Wahl verlieren und
da sind nur mal SPD Grüne und
Linkspartei die lassen immer ganz raus
aber SPD und Grüne gucken wie sie sich
ar passieren können mit dem klaren
Wahlsieger du hast ja gesagt ja du
glaubst auch dass es am Ende so kommt
das ist
können wir auch eine Wetter abschließen
das ist zu einer großen Koalition haben
wir inwiefern es kann auch Schwarz-Grün
sein das weiß ich nicht aber ich glaube
das ist eine Regierung unter CDU-Führung
geben wird und wie inwiefern spielt da
dann auch das Posten Geschacher am Ende
eine Rolle also dass die SPD
beispielsweise sich vielleicht dann doch
darauf einlässt und sagt na ja dann
nehmen wir uns aber auch die wichtigen
Posten ganz klar ist auf jeden Fall bei
einer gegebenen Zahlen Senatoren posten
und am Ende und das sehen wir hier auch
geht's am Ende nur um macht es geht um
Posten es geht auch da natürlich um Geld
und am Ende ist eine zweier Koalition so
bitte das jetzt auch sich der
Steuerzahler ist aber immer attraktiver
für Parteien weil es dann mehr posten
für die eigenen Parteien gibt das ist
ein Grund und das ist eine Sache jetzt
einfach nur aus politischer Sicht
deswegen ich glaube das ist eher zu
einem zweier Bündnis kommen wird andere
Gründe spielt auch eine Rolle aber weil
es natürlich für die Grünen attraktiver
ist in ein Bündnis mit der CDU
beispielsweise zu gehen weil es dort
mindestens ein Senatoren Posten mehr
geben wird als in einem Dreierbündnis so
und es kann aber auch ein Grund sein für
die SPD zusammen okay bevor wir hier nur
vier Senatoren Posten bekommen mit der
CDU zusammen fünf
am Ende spielt das eine Rolle das ist
bitter weil es hier gar nicht um die
Frage geht wie machen wir die Stadt
besser hier geht's rein und macht kein
kühl aber das Schauermärchen die sind
Horrorfilm den wir jetzt sehen der ist
wirklich wirklich das Gegenteil dessen
was der Bundeskanzler Lars klingen bei
Saskia uns alle groß am Wahlabend vor 17
Monaten erzählt haben ist das Gegenteil
dessen es ist ehrlicherweise ja es ist
ein Horrorfilm gewesen der Horrorfilm
wie wirkt der Herr Plutz ein Franke in
Berlin heute Abend schön äh ich bin aus
Franken ja das ist korrekt und noch
einmal wenn man das ja wegen anschaut
und mal ganz ehrlich es würde in keinem
anderen Bundesland wäre es so etwas
möglich in keinem anderen Bundesländern
ja aber ja aber nicht in der Form nicht
in der Form mit zwei mit drei Wahl
verlieren zwei klaren einigermaßen
klaren und drei klar und ein klaren
Sieger aber was man fairerweise auch
dazu sagen muss die CDU hat zwar
gewonnen aber die Wahl nicht gewonnen
weil wie meine ich das sie hat trotzdem
keine Möglichkeit keine strategische
Mehrheit wie so schön heißt dafür war
die FDP zu schwach auch da kann man viel
drüber sprechen völlig zu Recht übrigens
zu schwach ich bin da gar nicht unfroh
drüber aber das schöne an Berlin muss
man auch mal sagen ist ja die
hervorragende Verkehrsanbindung in nicht
mal drei Stunden ist man wieder in
Süddeutschland also das Schönste für Sie
an Berlin ist die A100 Richtung München
aber ja aber dass die Partei von Helmut
Schmidt beispielsweise überhaupt
paktiert mit der Linkspartei die auf
ihrer Internetseite noch mal eine große
Würdigung von Hans Modrow dem letzten
Ministerpräsidenten der Diktatur DDR
Abdruck noch mal ihre Trauer zum
Ausdruck bringt erwiesenerweise ein
Wahlfälscher ähm erwiesenermaßen jemand
der das System SED der Mensch
unterdrückt hat in Knechte gebracht hat
sozusagen gestützt hat dass eine Partei
wie die SPD mit der Tradition der der
auch mit diesem stolz sich überhaupt in
Berlin ausnimmt mit der mit der mit
diesem SED Nachfolgern koalieren zu
können und das in Betracht zieht
angesichts dieser Lage das
weiterzumachen
dass das ist kaum in Worte zu fassen
ehrlich gesagt
definitiv und ein Zitat von Moto wo er
meinte die Mauern Toten ja da hätten
beide Seiten Schuld also ich meine was
will ich dazu noch sagen und mit dieser
ehemaligen Ex SED noch SED wird koaliert
ich finde das ja zutiefstäbig wir fassen
also zusammen die Politik die kümmert
sich vor allem um sich selbst dabei gibt
es Themen die sind so viel wichtiger und
müssen auf der Agenda ganz ganz oben
stehen
Kindesmissbrauch das ist das große Thema
von Carsten Stahl denn da fordern sie
muss es endlich härtere Strafen geben
eigentlich wurde ich vor allen Dingen
dass die Gesetze die da sind die er hart
genug sein könnten umgesetzt werden denn
das werden sie nicht eine dieser immer
wiederkehrenden Schlagzeilen ein Mann
Missbrauch 129 mal ein Kind zweieinhalb
Jahren und genau das ist auch so das was
oft in unserem Land passiert dass
Kinderschänder Kinder missbrauchen nicht
nur einfach Dutzend nach hundertfach und
eigentlich mit zweieinhalb Jahren auf
Bewährung freigelassen werden oft folgt
dann vielleicht sogar noch nach der
Taten den Multi liegt ja dann gibt es
natürlich höhere Strafen aber es wird
immer wieder und das merkt man toleriert
verharmlost und runtergespielt was das
ganze passiert ich war jetzt gerade in
Österreich weil dann gerade ein sehr
bekannter Schauspieler mit 58
digitalen Dateien von Kinderpornographie
erwischt wurde und Österreich ist noch
ein bisschen konservativer wie wir hier
und auch dort na ja hat man nicht so
richtig Einverständnis dafür und ich
sag's klar in Deutschland klar und
deutlich Deutschland und Österreichs
sind Paradise für Kinderschänder und
deshalb bin ich untergefahren und wir
haben da protestiert vom Landesgericht
weil wir hoffen der kommt hat an dem Tag
krank gemacht ich war nicht verwundert
ist ja auch oft dass da passiert und
dann habe ich eine Rede gehalten der
sehr klar und deutlich wahrscheinlich zu
deutlich für Österreich aber sie haben
sie zumindestens gesagt und habe mich
gefragt wieso das so ist und wir haben
und jetzt nicht dazu mit Bündnis
Kinderschutz dass ihr in Deutschland und
Österreich haben Gesetzesvorschläge die
wir in Deutschland verabschiedet haben
Kinder Sexpuppen verboten Handbuch für
Pädophile eintragungs Führungszeugnis
lebenslang für Lehrer die Kinder
missbraucht haben und Kinderpornografie
zum Verbrechen gemacht haben wir den
Copy und Pest gegeben ein Parteien keine
bis auf einen hat auf reagiert und hat
diesen
Gesetzesentwurf mit eingebracht er wurde
abgelehnt Stempel magistratstempel
abgelehnt und vom Nationalrat und
Gemeinderat und ein halbes Jahr später
und nur durch den Fall teichmeister und
da würden überhaupt nicht drüber reden
in Österreich wenn ihr gewesen ist und
jetzt sagt stellt er nee haben ich bin
als Vater total betroffen da müssen was
machen und da habe ich gesagt Ernährung
Oma wo waren Sie denn vom halben Jahr
sind abgelehnt haben
ich bin Kampfsportler ich fordere Sie
zum Kampf im Ring für die Kinderschutz
heraus wie sie können so weiter nichts
machen ich schützen sie endlich die
Kinder sie setzen die Gesetze um das
geht nicht nur für Österreich ja aber
warum tue ich das ich will
sensibilisieren ich bin anders ich bin
laut ich bin direkt ich bin unbequem ja
aber wir gehen Kinder verdammt noch mal
die Zukunft unseres Landes sind die
Kinder und wenn dann sowas sehe und wir
waren gerade bei Berlin Berlin hat einen
Riesenskandal gehabt ein Kändler
Experiment ein nachweislicher
Kinderschänder ein Professor den man hat
der durchgehen lassen hat von 1974 bis
2004 in ein Experiment Kinder aus
schweren Familienverhältnissen oder von
Straße in die Hand mit Unterstützung des
Senats und der Schulen die dann
teilweise mit zuständig war in die Hand
von Kinderschändern gegeben weil man
damit zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe
geschlagen hat man hat die Kinder von
der Straße bekommen oder von dem aus den
Familien und Kinderschänder sind das ist
der Täter geworden nicht öffentlich
wurden sie bis heute entschädigt nein
wurden die Täter zur Strecke gemacht
nein die Mittäter nein was hat Berlin
gemacht unter Verschluss Sache gestellt
ich schäme mich für unser Bundesland
hier habe ich schäme mich auch dafür
dass eine Gesellschaft immer noch so tut
als wenn es kein Problem gibt und wenn
dann jemand wie ich oder andere laut und
direkt ansprechen dann müsste man lieber
diejenigen diskreditieren oder an
schlecht machen die darüber reden ich
will nur eins ich will dass die Kinder
geschützt werden und mal ganz ehrlich
neuneinhalb Jahre habe ich mich bewiesen
hatte gemacht wir haben Gesetze
umgesetzt und nicht nur hier sondern in
Österreich und noch mal ich bitte nicht
darum die Kinder zu schützen ich
verlange da rum wir alle haben Kinder
Enkelkinder oder nach was Kinder wir
sehen sie und noch mal pro Tag werden in
Deutschland 50 Kinder offiziell
missbraucht und inoffiziell mit
Sicherheit drei bis fünfmal höher über
18.000 offizielle killten Missbrauch
Zahlen in Deutschland und in der
Pandemie davor haben wir gewarnt ist
alles noch mal geschrieben nachweislich
wir können mal nachlesen und trotzdem
ist es immer noch so alle Themen kommen
oben warum Kinder können nicht wählen
Kinderzeit keine Steuern Kinder nutzt
der Politik erstmal wenn sie Kohle
bringt und ich könnte so unerträglich
die morale einer gefällt sagt zeigt sich
in dem was sie für ihre Kinder tut euch
Bonhoeffer gesagt
haben und ich denke mal wir sollten
jetzt langsam mal den Arsch hochkriegen
und sagen unsere Kinder sind wertvoll
wir haben in der Pandemie bewiesen dass
alles über den Rücken der Kinder
ausgetragen wurde die Kinder haben
Schule haben Wissenslücken und sie sind
weiter der prellbein und ich habe die
Schnauze und da kennt man mich dass sich
das doch hin und dafür kämpfig und
deshalb auch meine klare meine Forderung
an die andere Regierung und auch an die
wünsch dir was Regierung von Berlin
schützt die Kinder ich helfe euch gerne
dabei und wenn ihr nicht der Meinung
seid ihr macht weiter mache ich euch
weiter so viel Feuer und dann Arsch dass
ihr bald ja dass euch der dampfen weil
aus den Ohren kommt da könnt ihr euch
sicher sein und Millionen von Menschen
stehen hinter mir und wir werden nicht
aufgeben die Kinder die Augen meiner
Kinderserie die heute schon größer sind
da sehe ich einfach das ist unsere
Pflicht ist für meine Kinder für ihre
Kinder das vorzubereiten noch habe Dampf
auf der Brust aber ein paar Jahren nicht
mehr es ist meine Pflicht als Vorbild
als Vater dafür zu sorgen dass die
Kinder von morgen nicht die Opfer sind
die wir jetzt schon haben wir müssen
etwas verändern ich weiß wir schaffen
das ja und nicht nur so sondern wir
schaffen das wenn wir uns einfach ans
Herz fassen und die Kinder in unserem
Land genauso schützen den anderen
Ländern ganz ganz großes emotionales
Thema für Sie Carsten Stahl sie sprechen
ja auch mit vielen
Opfern mit Familien sie wissen was
diesen Kindern zustößt wie die sich
fühlen ja kannst du diese wuts diese
Hilflosigkeit die auch aus dieser Rede
von Carsten Stahl gerade spricht diese
Verzweiflung kannst du die
nachvollziehen passiert zu wenig wird zu
wenig geschaut wird zu wenig Acht
gegeben macht die Politik zu wenig wo
sie sowohl liegst du den Finger da in
die Wunde ich glaube das ist bei dem
Thema Kindesmissbrauch zu in der Tat zu
wenig zu wenig Debatten öffentliche
Debatten gibt und wenn man in Schulen
schaut
auch in Grundschulen und dort mitbekommt
dass es bereits Kinder gegeben hat die
offensichtlich Erfahrung gemacht haben
die man eigentlich niemandem wünscht
auch keinem Erwachsenen dann ist das ähm
ja wie soll man sagen also eigentlich
fehlen einem die Worte dafür
fürchterlich ist
da werden ganze Leben eigentlich in
jungen jungen Jahren komplett auf
deutsch gesagt versaut und
was können wir tun das ist eine große
Frage ich glaube das ist durchaus
dafür Mechanismen gibt um auch stärker
aufzupassen aber die Pandemie hat
natürlich viele viele Kinder aus einem
öffentlichen Raum nämlich dem Schulraum
zurückgeholt in einen Raum über Monate
indem sie dann dem einen oder dem
anderen komplett hilflos ausgeliefert
worden
die offiziellen Zahlen ist hatte ich
noch vergessen ist in unserer wir haben
in jeder Klasse so sagen wir also da
natürlich auch größeren Klassen ein bis
zwei missbrauchte Kinder mittlerweile
also in jeder Klasse kann man sagen
sitzen maximal schon zwei Kinder
missbraucht wurden das ist ein so großes
Problem und wir reden ja nicht über
Kindesmissbrauch wir reden auch von der
Verharmlosung zum Beispiel bei
teichmeister von Kinderpornografie und
dann geht das los und die sagen das ja
ähm dann ist die Frage wer kümmert sich
eigentlich um die Kinder macht das
Jugendamt natürlich aber dann haben Sie
natürlich auch Lehrer die
darf völlig überfordert sind und jetzt
kommen wir zum nächsten Problem da gibt
es die
speziellen oder auch Sonderschulen nicht
mehr wo solche Kinder ja dann auch eine
viel bessere er Treue Betreuung erfahren
würden nämlich auf Stärke auf Sie
zugeschnitten diese Kinder sind jetzt in
normalen Klassen unterwegs das heißt die
sind in gewisser Weise hilflos die
anderen Schülerinnen und Schüler sind
auch hilflos weil sich der Lehrer
überfordert oft sehr sehr stark mit
diesen ein zwei Kindern in der Klasse
auseinandersetzen muss das heißt sie
haben eigentlich auch wenn wir da beim
Thema dann auch sind wie geht man auch
was schafft man für Räume für diese
Kinder wird auch da eigentlich werden
diese Kinder extrem allein gelassen und
werden jetzt sage ich so soll es nicht
klingen wie ich sage aber auch zu einer
Belastung auch für andere Kinder und das
das kann nicht gut sein Thema übrigens
wenn dann die Kinder die dort mehr
Aufmerksamkeit bekommen und die anderen
spüren werden sie oft zu Mobbing Opfer
das heißt das ist so ein kleiner
Übergang ja es hat eine Dynamik ja
Wahnsinn ja ich bin immer anders ich bin
immer anders und das ist auch für Kinder
nicht schön wenn man immer im Fokus
steht egal was man macht immer die
sonderstunde mit dem Lehrer nach dem
Unterrichtstag noch mal hat für eine
Stunde zusammenzusitzen man ist immer
was besonderes vielleicht will man das
gar nicht sein vielleicht will man
einfach ganz normal sein aber in einem
in einem Raum mit dem das möglich ist
das
Hilflosigkeit wegschauen fehlt es uns da
auch eine Gesellschaft an Zivilcourage
mehr Wachsamkeit mehr wenn ich diese
Zahlen höre die Carsten Schalke gerade
gesagt hat dass es in jeder Kita Gruppe
betroffene Kinder gibt derzeit heißt es
einem das Herz und da sind wir doch auch
als Gesellschaft alle gefragt wir sind
inzwischen eine Angst bestimmte
Gesellschaft aber ich komme darauf
nochmal zurück ihr ich bin nicht so
emotional engagiert wieder Herr Strahl
aber ich habe selbst fünf Kinder und ich
war oft immer wieder dankbar dafür dass
bisher also die meisten sind schon
erwachsen von den Kindern das ist gar
keine Fälle von von Missbrauch
Misshandlung und so weiter gab ich
glaube wir haben ein ganz großes Problem
hier
kindesmissbrauch ist nur eines der
einer schwierigen Themen wir haben eine
Angst vor der populismus-keule in der
öffentlichen Debatte eine riesen Angst
vor der populismuskeule und die kommt
zum Beispiel auch beim Thema
Ausländerkriminalität es ist unheimlich
es gibt Missstände in diesem Land die
kaum einer große ausnahmestrahlt die
kaum einer anzusprechen wagt weil weil
die populismus-keule sofort zurückkommt
weil wir alle wissen dass es Menschen
gibt auf der extrem rechten die sagen
Kinderschänder kastrieren oder
wegsperren also ganz böse sagen ja das
gehört genauso zum Thema beim Thema
Ausländer Kriminalität haben wir das
gleiche deswegen meine ich Angst
bestimmte Gesellschaft für eine haben
eine Angst bestimmte öffentliche Debatte
die deren Teilnehmer nicht mehr in der
Lage sind hat er quasi diesen Problemen
zu werden und deswegen das bringt
eigentlich die Populismus Gefahr das
nämlich dann sich Themen so wir haben ja
vorhin schon mal über Reformstau
gesprochen mit sprechen eigentlich über
lauter Themen heute die mit Reform Stau
mit der mit der Notwendigkeit das was
dass ich was ändert zu tun haben ja und
wir sind leider in der Lage wie Franz
Josef Strauß mal früher gesagt hatte den
70er 80er Jahren die Dinge müssen erst
viel schlimmer werden bevor sie besser
werden und das ist ein Jammer weil das
wird auf den schwächsten auf diesen
Opfern ausgetragen
Herr plus wir haben gerade gehört
angstgetriebene Gesellschaft wir haben
zu viele Angst und deswegen passiert
auch das jetzt in unserer Gesellschaft
ein ganz vielen Ecken gibt es hier
Probleme auf jeden Fall Angst frisst
nicht nur Seele auf sondern auch oftmals
den Verstand das ist leider so und bei
dem Thema was hoch emotional ist ich
kann natürlich sehr sehr gut
nachempfinden diese Emotionalität da
frage ich mich tatsächlich wo ist denn
der Staat der Staat hat ein genuine ist
eine genuine Aufgabe das ist
sicherheitssorgen und wenn der Staat das
nicht hinkriegt und der Staat das nicht
schafft dann hat er versagt und wenn
diese Zahlen hören
ein bis zwei Kindern in pro Kita da
dreht es mir wirklich den den Marken um
und da frage ich mich neben der
Zivilgesellschaft wichtiger Punkt auch
wo ist denn der Staat wenn du immer
braucht der Staat ist sehr gut in Sachen
Wohlstand Verteilung von
Sozialleistungen hervorragend ähm im
Wahlkampf von Berlin kann man da ganz
viel Tolles entdecken aber auch bei
anderen Wahlkämpfen oder dann später
aber wenn es um das die Aufgabe geht
Sicherheit für Sicherheit zu sorgen dann
und dann haben sie wiederum recht geht
es dann in die Richtung ja Populismus ja
dann sagen die Leute ja das darfst oder
wohl nicht mehr sagen diese Sprichwort
ja klar kann man sagen kommt drauf an
was danach halt kommt nee neuneinhalb
Jahren habe ich ja viele Gespräche
geführt ja und ich weiß jetzt mal die
Namen weg da gab es auch welche die mir
gesagt haben ah Kindes Thema
Kindesmissbrauch Kinder
zu mir dafür nur scheiße weil die AFD
vielleicht hier darüber redet oder
vielleicht auch benutzt der geht doch um
die Kinder die kann doch nicht daran per
se sagen nee möchte ich nicht ja weiß
ich vielleicht sage ich mal Klimaschutz
oder andere Themen besser verkaufen
lassen hier geht's um die Kinder und
wenn wir nämlich so anfangen dann ist
das ja ein Tabuthema nur darüber zu
reden und diese Populismus Gäule ob er
das ein oder andere Thema ist die
meisten sind immer wieder ich sage mal
steckt euch ihre Nazi Keule sonst wohin
ja das geht mir um das Thema und es
werden ja alle Kinder
von christlichen und deutschen Kinder
die Opfer von missbraucht werden das
sind auch Kinder mit muslimischen
asiatischen Hintergrund das geht um alle
Kinder zu schützen deswegen finde ich
das so schlimm dass man überhaupt in
einem Land wo man über den Schutz von
Kindern diskutieren und betteln muss in
dem Leben und dafür schäme ich mich als
Bürger und mit meiner Nationalität und
deswegen ändern
die ihre Kinder ganz vorne haben konnte
nicht eins unter den ersten 20 30 gehen
sein muss ja nicht gleich Klimaschutz
verdrängen aber bitte nicht
aber bitte nicht
ignorieren totschweigen und zu tun als
wenn Sie unsere Kinder nichts wert sind
in Österreich wollen sie in den Kampf
gehen mit dem Kanzler nehammer um
endlich aufmerksam zu machen auf das
Thema was halten Sie für die geeignete
Aktionen hier in Deutschland darauf
Aufmerksamkeit
machen aber ich finde ich finde es
sondern ich bin eine Person ist
öffentlichen Lebens ich habe meinen
Namen mein Ruf genommen und wird mich
diesen Film auch mit aufs Spiel gesetzt
weil du bist ja dafür auch in der Ecke
gedrückt hier und da ich frage mich wo
sind eigentlich die ganzen lauten
berühmten Sportler
Musiker und ganz ganz Idole nein das ist
ziemlich genau diese Angst davor
irgendwie unbequem zu sein warum machen
wir nicht mal ein Event von mir aus
warum boxt nicht mal zwei große Boxer
oder egal oder Musiker Musiker für den
Kinderschutz und war ganz effizient für
das Thema gegen Kindesmissbrauch Gewalt
an Kindern die Mobbing und Kindern nein
das ist so hmm guck mal was nutzt es mir
oder ich mache es nur wenn sie mir nicht
schadet wie denkt meine Sponsoren
darüber ich scheiß darauf was man über
mich denkt mir geht's nur eins wenn ich
an diesem grä Bern stehen und diese
Eltern sehe die ihre Kinder verloren
haben wenn ich im richtigen Teil höre
wie ein Tim missbraucht und getötet
wurde dann machte was mit mir und macht
mich stinksauer und eins können Sie mir
glauben Liebe Politik einen Neuköllner
jungen stinkst aber nackten zu haben da
gibt's Dinge die wollte nicht
ist ja auch ein emotionales Thema ich
würde noch wirklich sehr gerne weil das
mich über Jahre hinweg und bis heute
bestimmt auch viele andere bewegt dieses
das darfst du nicht sagen dann ist das
AFD dann ist man in der falschen Ecke
wenn die AFD sagt das wasser ist nass
ist es dann plötzlich trocken oder was
also das ist ja unglaublich und es kann
auch sein dass von jemand sogar von der
Linkspartei was gute sagt das ist das
halt nun mal so es geht um die Inhalte
und in Deutschland ist es geht nicht
darum was man sagt sondern es geht darum
wer sagt es und vor allen Dingen wo sagt
man das darf man auch nicht vergessen
wenn man in der falschen falschen
momentan der falschen Veranstaltung was
sagt er gibt sich darum welchen welches
Wort man gesagt hat und wer war da oder
wer war ein Publikum mittlerweile geht
ja schon so weit dass man sagt okay wer
hat den dazugehört oder wem könnte es
etwas nutzen ist es doch völlig egal ob
es einer Partei etwas nutzen oder nicht
nutzt wenn denn der Inhalt passt und in
der inhaltlich passt dann falsch ist
dann kann man sich dann eben inhaltlich
auseinandersetzen aber bitte nicht auf
dieser wirklich guten ähm ja diese diese
kontaktschull-ding das ist sowas von
zutiefst Deutsch zutiefst peinlich und
abzuleben
wir bleiben in diesem Thema dran
vielleicht gibt es Prominente die sich
mehr einsetzen wollen die lauter werden
wollen bei diesem Thema dass uns alle
hier tief tief berührt haben sie uns in
den Sendung reden wir darüber wie atmen
hier einmal kurz durch wir sind gleich
zurück nach einer ganz kurzen Pause mit
weiteren wichtigen Themen nach acht
da sind wir wieder mit 8:15 Uhr schön
dass ihr bei uns sind ja die EU die
debattiert über weitere
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine hier in
Deutschland macht aber das
friedensmanifest von Alice Schwarzer und
Sarah Wagenknecht die Runde er Plot sie
sagen dieses Manifest ist mittlerweile
fast eine halbe Million Menschen
unterzeichnet haben darunter auch viele
Prominente Liedermacher Reinhard Meier
ist dabei Schauspielerin Katharina
Thalbach sie sagen da ist man auf dem
Holzweg im Gegenteil mit Putin kann man
keine Gespräche führen da zählt Härte
ihr Thema ja ähm Alice Schwarzer und
Frau Wagenknecht machen ein Manifest
dass ich nennt das friedensmann ist fest
oder dass meine beste Freundin das Frau
Wagenknecht mit manifesten sich auskennt
ist hinreichend bekannt Stichwort das
von meine Schwester der Kommunistischen
Partei warum geht es da im Wesentlichen
wenn man sich das anschaut und
durchliest geht es um die Kapitulation
natürlich steht es da nicht drin
explizit nicht aber es ist so gewollt
oder zum so explizit so gemeint ich
frage mich immer okay man kann alles
Mögliche fordern man kann sagen das und
das man kann sagen ich sehe das kritisch
ich sehe das kritischer wo aber mein
Problem beginnt ist wenn Leute die
fachfremd sind und zwar im Wesentlichen
sind das also Frau Wagenknecht ist eine
hervorragende Komponistin Frau Schwarzer
ist eine Feministin und ich habe das
tatsächlich gerade letzten Jahren macht
er eine finde ich sehr sehr
hervorragende Arbeit aber ich finde es
sehr sehr merkwürdig dass Leute die
keine große Expertise haben nicht nur
eine ein Thema bespielen das mag sein
aber schon auch gleich die Lösung haben
ich bin mir 100 % sicher dass die erst
Unterzeichner auch den Nahost-Konflikt
lösen werden weil sie schon einen
kompletten Konzept haben deswegen
Schuster bleibt ein leisten Reinhard
Meissen hervorragender Liedermacher
schätze ich sehr Frau Wagenknecht ist
eine charmante Persönlichkeit Frau
Schwarzer im Wesentlichen möglicherweise
auch bleibt wo ihr seid journalisten
sollten Journalisten sein und keine
Aktivisten
machen wir jetzt mal ganz konkret Herr
blutz wenn Sie Ihre Liste aufmachen
würden ein friedensmanifest sozusagen
was würde da gefordert werden jetzt in
der Abgrenzung zu diesem Manifest ja
genau das ist da beginnt schon das
Problem weil ich sowas nicht mache ich
bin Journalist ich schaue mir Sachen an
und ich bewerte sie aber ich bin niemand
der eine Lösung präsentiert hat das ist
überhaupt nicht die Aufgabe von
Journalisten wo kommen denn dahin dass
dann jeder jeder im Hans und Kunst jeder
Plutz jeder sonst irgendwer eine Lösung
parat hätte nein die Lösung sollen
Politik und Politiker machen sondern
meinetwegen Experten diese beraten Sie
nach Ihrer Bewertung ist die Politik
gerade mit ihren Schritten auf dem
richtigen Weg aus ihrer Sicht bezüglich
diesem Thema ich würde sagen im
Wesentlichen Jahren also ja
[Gelächter]
diplomatisch versprochen also nein ich
würde schon sagen dass die
Ampelkoalition schon die Zeichen der
Zeit erkannt hat man musste sie
natürlich immerhin tragen wie das wohl
bei Olaf Scholz üblich ist was die
Waffenlieferung angeht mit 5000 Helmen
kann man bestimmt den fahrradverein von
Nordrhein-Westfalen bestücken aber
keinen Krieg gewinnen in Sinne von
Ukraine deswegen würde ich schon sagen
dass die Politik die Zeichen der Zeit
erkannt hat aber viel zu langsam viel zu
wenig das heißt mehr
Waffenlieferung und sie hätten früher
kommen sollen falls sie zusammen auf
jeden Fall
sie sitzen neben mir sie lächeln ein
bisschen sie glaube ich Stimmen nicht
unbedingt direkt zu würden Sie denn
dieses Frieden Smiley fest unterzeichnen
oder bewerten sie mal die aktuelle
Politik als Mensch der schon erlebt hat
wie ein Mensch durch eine Kugel
gestorben ist und als Mensch geschossen
ist habe ich zu Gewalt und Waffen
eine ganz eigene Einstellung und bin
jemand der jahrelang gewalttätig war und
weiß wie schnell solche Konflikte von
Kleinen ganz groß werden und ich bin
normal und das werde ich auch immer sein
ein ganz ganz großer Verfechter von
Helmut Schmidt
und er hat gesagt lieber 100 Stunden
umsonst verhandeln als eine Stunde
schießen ja und ich sage immer wieder
ich versuche ich persönlich möchte
Frieden mit möchten wir alle ich weiß
aber auch dass auf der anderen Seite
jemand ist der diesen Druck ausübt der
begonnen hat und mit dem man vielleicht
auch nicht so verhandeln kann ich
befürchte nur immer eins und das ist
halt meine Gedanken ich weiß nicht wenn
man einen niemand Menschen in eine
gewisse Ecke drängt und deren vielleicht
nichts mehr zu verlieren hat der hat ja
nicht einfach nur Panzer untergeht und
ein paar Jets sondern er hat ein paar
Knöpfe da liegen und wir sind da alle
mit dabei und das ist immer mein Gedanke
das hier möchte ich bin auch kein
Experte aber auch diese Politik die wir
haben sind da keine Experten keiner von
denen der da sitzt
dass sich da wirklich welche
zusammenkommen und hoffentlich
irgendwann eine Lösung finden denn auf
beiden Seiten sterben Menschen und
sterben auch Kinder und ich finde das so
unsäglich was da alles passiert und die
kann nur hoffen oder das ist endlich ein
Ende nimmt aber befürchte dass wenn wir
das immer weiter forcieren und immer
mehr Waffen liefern oder nennen es auch
kampfschätze fordert werden und was auch
immer das hörte ich einfach vielleicht
bekommt man einen Punkt wo wir nicht
mehr rauskommen was für eine sehr im
Buch geschrieben über putinette teilen
Sie diese Befürchtung die Katzen Steiger
gerade auch aufgemacht hat dass wenn man
mehr Druck als Zeug dass er dann mit
Atomwaffen ähnlichen kommen könnte das
ist sicher ein Aspekt vor allem würde
ich aber sagen ich habe das ich habe das
Manifest völlig anders verstanden als
sie und zwar nicht als ähm als
Lösungsvorschlag für den für den Ukraine
Krieg ähm der in entsprechende Expertise
und diplomatische Kompetenz verlangt
sondern als Ausdruck der Angst der
verbreiteten Angst dass Deutschland in
diesem Krieg hineingezogen werden kann
als Kriegspartei und das ist zum Einsatz
von Nuklearwaffen kommt in dem Fall
durch den russischen Präsidenten und die
völlig gerechtfertigte Empörung über den
Krieg die völlig gerechtfertigte
verurstern und des Angriffs ja darf ja
trotzdem nicht dazu führen dass wir uns
in jedes mögliche
militärische Risiko begeben nur um einen
moralischen Missstand ja um einen ein
moralisches Unding wie diesen
Angriffskrieg der Russen entgegen zu
treten
die rote Linie wird wahrscheinlich
erreicht werden also da zieht hier ich
jetzt wieder nur die Experten die mir
zur Verfügung stehen wenn der Westen die
Brücke Eroberung der Krim durch die
Ukraine ist erfolgreich rechtlich ist
die Krim Ukraine wo kann ich direkt oben
wenn der Westen diese rückkehroberung
militärisch unterstützt also durch
entsprechende
Waffenlieferung unterstützt z.B
Langstrecken Raketen die bisher noch
nicht geliefert sind diese heimats dann
ist nicht ausgeschlossen das hat heute
morgen gerade aus ihrem Haus der
Christoph Wanner der weltkorrespondent
wieder bestätigt der in Russland lebt
den ich gut kenne ist einer der besten
Experten da und der eigentlich bei jeder
Gelegenheit sagt Leute unterschätzt den
Putin nicht irgendwo kommt bei den
Russen die rote Linie Viktor jerofee auf
die Russen sagen dasselbe ich habe 23
Jahre in Russland gelebt und anders
schätze ich die Russen auch nicht ein
ähm einfach Frank Weg zu sagen ach
quatsch die bluffen nur das wird nie
geschehen wäre eine eine große Dummheit
das ist so wie 1914 zu sagen Weihnachten
sind wir alle wieder zu Hause ich riecht
immer die Frage an sie würden sie
ich gehe mal davon aus dass sie sich für
den Sieg der Ukraine einsetzen würden
Sie sagen die Brücke Eroberung der Krim
also ukrainisches territoren ist
wichtiger als der Schutz Deutschlands
vor dem Eintritt in den Krieg allein das
wird irgendwie so schön heißt würde ich
schon ablehnen denn der Sieg der Ukraine
impliziert ja das ist eine kleine
Gleichgewicht sei was ja ein Unsinn es
ist ein Angriffskrieg ein Sieg von
Ukraine bedeutet einfach dass ähm
Russland aufhört diesen Krieg zu führen
interessant darum geht es und wenn ich
mir das noch mal anschaue diesen dieses
Manifest sie haben das anders
interpretiert das ist dann wohl
Interpretation gegen Interpretation aber
wenn ich etwas nenne Manifest für den
Frieden dann heißt das und das erlebe
ich in vielen Diskussionen wenn man denn
dies anders sieht ist man denn für Krieg
und das ist genau das Problem ich
wundere mich ehrlicherweise wenn ich das
mal sagen darf wie leichtfertig doch die
Freiheit eines Landes aufgegeben wird
zugunsten eines diktatorischen Regimes
also wie sieht das jetzt auch gerade
machen nicht wundern mich auch das
ausreichend wird Deutschland immer Angst
haben der NATO das NATO ähm
Verteidigungsbündnis ist ein relativ
großes wieso haben wir eigentlich immer
als deutsche Angst dass es ausgerechnet
dann nur die deutschen trifft es gibt ja
viele andere NATO-Länder die zum Teil
eine direkte Grenze dann auch haben oder
deutlich weiter im Osten liegen als wir
die doch viel eher betroffen sein würden
wenn die angegriffen werden wir sowieso
in dem Fall genau so und jetzt doch die
Frage wieso haben wir eigentlich Angst
wir sehen ja schon dass Russland jetzt
schon Probleme hat die die keine so zu
erobern wie sich das vorgestellt hat wie
Putin das erhofft hat wie das
wahrscheinlich auch Generäle erhofft
haben das ist klappt also wir sehen ja
dass die Russen zwar Vorankommen das ist
schlimm genug aber das ist offenbar
alles viel viel schwieriger ist und ich
verstehe ehrlicherweise nicht wir würden
glaube ich wenn wir über den Einbruch in
einem Haus ich habe das Beispiel hier
schon ab und zu mal gebracht wenn wir
über den Einbruch in einem Haus sprechen
würden würden wir doch nie sagen dass
der Einbrecher die Chance hat unten das
ganze Erdgeschoss einzunehmen und sich
die Familie die da wohnt in ersten Stock
zurückziehen würde würde jeder von uns
sagen soll man spinnt ihr denn wo ist
die Polizei warum greift die nicht ein
würde nicht jemand auf die Idee kommen
wieso sind wir bei einem freien dann
wieder Ukraine eigentlich so so so so so
so so bereit das zu geben weil wir Angst
haben als Deutsche Bank man könnte uns
angreifen warum sollte Putin das
eigentlich machen mit welcher Begründung
es geht nicht darum dass Deutschland
gezogen werden
Krieg in den Krieg hineingezogen werden
wir miteinander möglicherweise mit jedem
also die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir in
den Krieg hineingezogen werden steigt
mit jeder Eskalation ja die letzte
Eskalation wäre zum Beispiel eine
taktische Nuklearwaffe gegen Geograf
mit der Logik wer ist doch ein Leichtes
für Putin die Ukraine zu nehmen dann
fängt damit Polen an was macht er dann
wenn er nämlich Polen angreift sind wir
automatisch im Krieg mit dabei ja und
dann wir stehen davor aber wie die Frage
ist doch lassen wir und peacement hat
sie ja schon mal gegeben die die Folgen
davon sind bekannt lassen wir das zu
oder lassen wir das nicht so wie weit
stelle ich Ihnen die Frage würden sie um
der Befreiung der kompletten Ukraine
Willen einen Kriegseintritt der NATO
riskieren was glauben Sie denn das
Putins Panzer plötzlich durch Polen nach
Deutschland rollen nein nein ein
Kriegseintritt kann nicht kann immer das
Deutschland in den Krieg gezogen wird
weil dann hier plötzlich Putins Panzer
sind er hat jetzt schon Probleme durch
die Ukraine zu räumen ich bin kein
Militärexperte wie der ex-generei
Domröse überhaupt nicht aber wir müssen
glaube ich mal auch dann einfach mal ein
paar Dinge in der Realität betrachten
putin ist nicht in der Lage Dank
natürlich auch massiver westlicher Hilfe
die Ukraine ein dem so wie er das
vorgehabt hat jetzt glauben wir er wird
das Ganze nato-bündnis angreifen darum
geht es nicht doch
Szenario aber was ist dein Fantasie
herangehen Werne es sind verschiedene
Dinge diskutiert worden
nuklearer taktischer nuklearer Angriff
in der Ukraine gegen die Ukraine zum
Beispiel im Zusammenhang mit der
Verhinderung der Krim Rückeroberung
würde möglicherweise Spekulation von den
Amerikanern mit einem massiven
konventionellen Angriff auf sevastopel
erwidert werden dann würden die
Amerikaner
das so so wahrscheinlich so machen dass
sie die NATO nicht diesen Krieg
hineinziehen wollen aber wir rücken mit
jedem dieser Schritte näher an die
Eskalation heran die wahrscheinlich sie
und ich am Ende auch nicht wollen aber
es geht
Deutschland
fragen was ist denn ihr Vorschlag ihre
Alternative zu sagen verhandel heißt ja
alles mögliche man wer will er nicht
verhandeln
interessanterweise richten sich am
meistens immer an die Ukraine das ist ja
das komische
diese Appelle müssten sich rein an
Wladimir Putin richten und diese Heeren
Ziele wir müssen miteinander reden
vollkommen richtig möglicherweise und
das versucht ja auch der Bundeskanzler
wieder lässt sich mit Wladimir Putin
nicht reden wenn der Bundeskanzler den
Hörer aufgelegt hat dann sagt er ja
selbst er hat den Eindruck er redet mit
jemandem der offenbar einen auf einer
ganz anderen Welt leben sie völlig recht
mit so Leben
immer wieder so populistisch sein und
sagen wir müssen verhandeln nein ich
sage das ja nicht aber genau
ich habe das Manifest verstanden als
Ausdruck der Angst der Deutschen vor dem
Krieg und ich haltet aber was heißt
nicht wahr sein
nicht verhandeln und keine Waffen
liefern heißt ja nicht schweigen schon
sehr vorsichtig sondern nichts anderes
ist der Bundeskanzler er ist sehr sehr
vorsichtig bei der Lieferung von Waffen
und da bin ich völlig auf seiner Seite
ich unterstütze ganz ganz ausdrücklich
die Politik der Bundesregierung vor
allem des Bundeskanzlers der zwar der
nicht auf Verhandlungen setzt weil das
gesehen los ist ja der aber sehr
vorsichtig ist vorsichtig ist bei der
Eskalation von Waffenlieferung das
sollten wir sein die vor mir kommt durch
die Vorsicht an gewachsen aus der Angst
dessen was sie beschrieben habe
hier aufgefangen das haben wir gesehen
Leute Diskussion die Panzerlieferungen
von vielen Menschen in Deutschland da
was mehr oder weniger 50% zu 50 %. dies
befürwortet haben und dies abgelehnt
haben meine Frage daher an Sie Karsten
Stahl glauben Sie dass sich dieses
Stimmungsbild in die ein oder andere
Richtung jetzt haben wir fast ein Jahr
Krieg in Deutschland in ein oder andere
Richtung entwickeln kann also sprich
wird er die Unterstützung wir alle sind
vom Krieg betroffen zunehmend schwinden
bei dem deutschen sehen sie da so eine
Tendenz also länger so aus meiner Sicht
so länger im Krieg dauert umso mehr
gewöhnt man sich ja leider auch daran
das ist natürlich auch so eine
Bequemlichkeit die dann passiert und wir
waren vorhin bei dem geht für alles
manchmal muss es erst schlimmer werden
bevor alle Aufwachen ich befürchten muss
wenn das hier schlimmer wird egal auf
welcher Seite dann dann wird das
schlimmer werden das ist halt mein
Gedanke ich bin mir hundertprozentig
sicher dass man dass man versucht zu
verhandeln und das ist auf ich denke
einfach das war ja mein Gedanke dass sie
auch gerade gesagt haben wenn der
Kanzler mit ihm telefoniert und sagt er
spricht mit jemanden der vom anderen
Planeten ist das ist ja genau mein
Gedanke wenn der so tickt und so ist ja
das ist eine andere Welt ist was geht in
seinem Kopf vor da sind wir alle nicht
dabei ja und ich weiß nicht ich damit
kenne ich mich nicht nur aus wie der der
im regeln kann der alleine so etwas
lostreten oder braucht er viele andere
die dazu mitwirken und sagen zum Schluss
nee bei dem bei diesem Spiel machen wir
nicht mit aber wie schlimm soll es denn
noch werden ich meine das Massaker von
Butcher sitzt irgendwie 10 Monate alt
und ähm da hat man genau gesehen das
haben die Ukraine gesehen was passiert
wenn die Ukraine eingenommen wird
nämlich am ersten Tag mit geschossen als
zweiten Tag wird vergewaltigt so einfach
ist es und wenn das zulässt dann kann
man sagen okay dann wartet man ab dann
kann man einen Friedensappell
unterschreiben man kann sie das auch
sogar mal die fest nennen unbedingt
sogar da hat man auch mal ein bisschen
Presse aber es ändert überhaupt nichts
ich habe mich vielleicht habe ich auch
falsch gegoogelt aber ich kenne keinen
einzigen Konflikt der aufgrund eines
manifestes beendet wurde was alles
schwarzer und Sahra Wagen kriegt
eigentlich machen müssen wer der große
Appell an die russischen Frauen stirbt
den stürmt den Krimml und jagt diesen
völligen bekloppten Idioten aus dem
Kreml das wäre der Appellen der wäre
auch mutig und an die schwarzen daran
sollten nach Moskau fahren
dort eine große Demonstration machen vor
dem krimin das wäre wirklich mutig aber
sich hier in Berlin irgendwohin zu
stellen und auch noch an und und auch
noch an die an die Ukraine zu
appellieren ja das ist nun wirklich also
selber
es gibt das hat mit der Wirklichkeit
nichts zu tun ja was russischen Frauen
werden nicht weil weil zwei deutsche
Prominente so ein Appell richten werden
nicht auf die Straße die Gegner vor
allem die in der jüngeren Generation
sind bereits integriert sind außerhalb
wir haben in Russland eine Zustimmung zu
dem Krieg von 70 80%
hilft der Sturz von Putin nichts anderes
hilft und wir wissen immer noch nicht
was dann an die Stelle tritt und ich
sage richtig ich möchte aber ich möchte
es nicht ich möchte es nicht drauf
ankommen lassen ja und meiner Pell wäre
wo sie gefragt haben konkret mein Appell
wäre unterstützt nicht unterstützt die
Ukraine bei der Befreiung der Ostukraine
aber nicht bei der Rückeroberung der
Krim denn ich befürchte ganz konkret das
wie gesagt die rote Linie auch für einen
Einsatz von Nuklearwaffen beim Versuch
erreicht sein wird wenn nicht eventuell
schon vorher aber da will ich jetzt den
Teufel nicht an die Wand malen bei der
Krim bin ich mir relativ sicher würden
sie auch reden bei den bayerischen
Staaten dass man sagt ja wenn ihr einen
baltischen Staat einnehmt also
vielleicht auch einen zweiten aber
der Russe will weder nach Polen noch zur
Elbe zur wir können jetzt hier mögliche
Szenarien aufmalen ja alles klar
nach Berlin er will auch nicht wieder
hier nach Mitte ja oder gegenüber bisher
haben wir die die Lage dass der dass der
Russe versucht hat und völlig auf die
Nase gefallen ist mit einem sowohl
moralisch als auch völkerrechtlich als
auch in jeder Hinsicht zu verurteilenden
krieg ja der aber nur einmal nach seit
11 Monaten Realität ist und die Realität
real ist auch die Unterstützung
weitgehende Unterstützung unterhalb der
russischen Bevölkerung wir reden in
Deutschland über die Clans die kleinsten
hier zum Teil machen können was sie
wollen warum weil der Rechtsstaat
zurückgewichen ist weil der Rechtsstaat
nicht Knall hat gegen vorgegangen ist
und was wir er mehr putin ist doch
nichts anderes je mehr man Putin
zurückweicht umso mehr mein Putin auch
Macht zu haben deswegen glaube ich ist
das was sie sagen komplett richtig es
geht nur mit knallharter Härte und wir
haben zum Glück in Sinn ein Bündnis mit
der führenden Militärmacht der Welt das
sind die Amerikaner wunderbar die
Bereitschaft ganz einzusteigen in diesem
Krieg wir haben doch selbst gesagt wo
die will gar nicht nach Deutschland will
Berlin gar nicht angreifen wenn das so
ist dann weiß ich gar nicht wofür wir
Angst haben wenn ihre Worte wenn ihre
Worte richtig sind schon bei Polen wir
können doch vergessen Artikel aber wo
leben wir dann wenn das die Verteilung
der Freiheit gegen einen aggresso und
Diktator offenbar dazu führt dass wir
uns schon Gedanken machen ja wollen wir
die Freiheit eigentlich Verteidigung
wollen wir es nicht was geben wir denn
ab damit der Adresse zu zufrieden ist
was werfe ich ihm hin dass er möglichst
ruhig bleibt ich weiß nicht ob der
danach wieder anfängt das ist da keine
Taktik die Taktik muss doch sein
knallhart hat Zero toll so wie in New
York aufgeräumt wurde Zero Toleranz und
das muss Herr Putin verstehen und wenn
das nicht verstanden hat dann ist das
sein Problem Theorie
weil sie nicht wie gegen Hitler
Deutschland eine Besatzung ein Sieg über
Russland erringen können es geht doch
nicht um ein Sieg über Russland wenn sie
durch sein wollen
doch gar keiner es geht dabei aber Sie
müssen wenn sie Russland zur Resort
zwingen wollen unter unseren nach
unseren Regeln nach den Regeln des
Völkerrechts nach den Regeln zur
europäischen Ordnung wenn sie Russland
zur Resort zwingen wollen müssen sie
doch Herrscher herrschend werden
überhaupt nicht erstmal geht's darum
russischen Truppen aus der Ukraine zu
vertreiben so und alles weitere Religion
vorher
vertrieben werden wenn die weiter
kämpfen wollen werden die sogar weiter
kämpfen Russland muss nicht mal Frieden
machen
wir in diesem Position nicht zusammen
und können das glaube ich in dieser
Runde jetzt heute auch nicht klären vor
allem haben wir noch ein Thema dass sie
auch sehr beschäftigt hat fast wenn er
von dem sie sagen das nimmt man nicht
ernst genug das wird uns alle noch
überrollen wenn wir nicht endlich beim
Klima wenn die Politik auch nicht
endlich entschieden gegensteuert wird ja
Frau Platin hat mich eben als
klimaaktivistin anmoderiert das ist ein
das ist richtig und falsch zugleich ich
bin vor allem ein Aktivist für die
Wahrheit ja der Wahrheit ins Gesicht zu
schauen die Erderwärmung ist ein Fakt
die Erderwärmung aufgrund der
Treibhausgase in der Atmosphäre die sich
anreichern die sich seit den letzten 220
Jahren fast annähernd verdoppelt haben
und die und das ist eine physikalische
Tatsache die einfach wie die Hitze unter
dem äh unter dem herdboden dazu führt
dass das Wasser im Topf irgendwann kocht
unseren Planeten erwärmen wie sich das
dann klimatisch wie sich das wettermäßig
regional und so weiter auswirkt steht
auf einem ganz anderen Blatt wir müssen
dieser Wahrheit ins Gesicht schauen und
das bedeutet zwei Dinge wir können das
Klima nicht retten und die Welt wird
nicht untergehen wir reden vom Prozessen
die Jahrzehnte und Jahrhunderte lang
andauern werden Dinge
besseres Spiegel
Anstieg der Meeresspiegel Veränderung
der Monsun der der großwetterzonen und
so weiter das wird uns in diesem
Jahrhundert und auch noch in diesem
Jahrhundert danach und dann nach
beschäftigen die Menschheit und insofern
ist wird auch immer Menschen geben die
sich mit dieser Sache auseinandersetzen
und deswegen gibt es zwei Ziele zwei
zwei Aufgaben die eine Aufgabe ist wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass die Erwärmung
der Erde das Planeten keine drei Grad
oder noch mehr übersteigt das können wir
nur durch einen Ausstieg kompletten
Ausstieg aus der
fossilenindustriegesellschaft der aber
nicht innerhalb von 10 oder 20 oder 30
Jahren zu erreichen sondern auch das ist
eine Aufgabe mindestens für dieses und
das nächste Jahrhundert das zweite ist
während wir dieses Ziel verfolgen
brauchen wir müssen wir uns anpassen an
die Veränderung des Klimas denn es wird
wärmer als die 1,5 Grad ist wird wärmer
als die zwei Grad weil dahinter eine 8
Milliarden Stärke industriell getriebene
Zivilisation steckt der Mensch 8
Milliarden Menschen sind wir auf dieser
Erde und erst dann wenn wir 8 Milliarden
dazu bewegen sich insgesamt also ihr
gesamtes ihr gesamten zivilisatorischen
Strukturen Verhalten und so weiter zu
ändern werden wir auch aus dieser
fossilen
Industriegesellschaft aussteigen können
mein Appell ist Anpassung Ja sagen zu
den Veränderungen anerkennen dass wir da
nicht tun können es wird keine Klima
Rettung geben wir werden damit leben
müssen wie vor 500 Jahren ja unsere
Vorfahren mit der Pest und anderen nicht
zu damals nicht zu besiegenden
Krankheiten gelebt haben wir werden uns
auf sehr vieles einstellen müssen es ist
ein bisschen so man kann nichts machen
aber man muss was machen
als Konsequenz wahrscheinlich haben wir
heute auch gehört dass das aus jetzt
beschlossene Sache für Verbrenner
Motoren bis 2035 war das für sie schon
längst überfällig
also was mich dann da kommen wir
bestimmt auch zu immer fraglich ist
schon vor vielen vielen Jahren ich kann
mich noch erinnern als
klein da gab es diese ganzen
Diskussionen schon und ich frag mich
immer wo ist eigentlich die ganze
Technik geblieben ja wir hat es gab
immer so diese Gedanken wenn du was
neues erfindest dann kommt die die
Ölindustrie und kauft das weg und packt
das ganz ganz tief in den Keller und ich
habe sogar das Gefühl wir bezahlen jetzt
schon damals wahrscheinlich war zu spät
jetzt den Preis dafür und ich denke es
ist einfach Zeit bestimmte Dinge noch zu
also endlich zu erschaffen oder die
Dinge rauszuholen lieber vielleicht
schon erschaffen haben wenn sie sich
wieder eine Verschwörungstheorie ist und
einfach mal nach vorne zu gucken weil
eins bin ich hundertprozentig sicher das
was wir schon angerichtet haben da
spielen wir jetzt noch nicht mal den
Schaden der kommt ja erst die Frage ist
wie wir gemeinsam dahin kommen und ich
glaube nicht dass dieses sich auf den
Straßenfest Leben und die Menschen
penetrieren und terrorisieren auf ein
gewisser Art oder diese ständige links
grüne geredet dass das wirklich dazu
bringt die Menschen umzudenken und zu
Vernunft anzuregen ihre Verhalten zu
ändern ja also es gibt so viele Dinge
die wir verändern können und für die
Leute auch zu bereit sind aber es bringt
verbote bringen da nichts es bringt mir
Aufklärung und die Menschen zu animieren
um zu denken und so schaffen wir diesen
Prozess auch aber ich denke und das ich
glaube ich auch dafür die diese ganzen
die Erhöhung der Temperaturen und das
wird erst alles eintreten dass wir uns
darauf angewöhnen müssen wenn man sich
mal hinguckt was man alles so auf der
Welt sieht dann sind wir schon damit
drin aber dass da welche immer noch
total blind rumlaufen und sagen das ist
so nicht oder ich will das alles
weiterhalten also ich brauche keinen
Verbrennungsmotor ich würde nicht
unbedingt Lastenfahrrad nehmen aber Fakt
ist es bringt auch nichts wenn die
Elektroautos haben wo du nur 20 Minuten
fahren kannst und mein ganzes ganz viel
Kohlestrom ist das und natürlich und wo
kommt diese Batterie her wer muss denn
alle dran schaffen wie viel Wasser
braucht also irgendwie ist das eine
Milchmädchen aus meiner Sicht und ja das
nutzt vielleicht der Grünen Ideologie
und auch dieser Partei gerade sehr stark
aber ich glaube das ist der falsche an
wenn wir die Menschen jetzt so versuchen
da so zurück wir müssen sie gewinnen so
vergraulen wir sie ja du schon ein
E-Auto bestellt Jan nein aber ich denke
darüber nach in der Tat bloß man muss
sich den Strom Mix anschauen und wir
haben das jetzt durch den Winter ja auch
wieder erlebt dass wir im Dezember zwei
Wochen oder Ende November bis Anfang
Mitte Dezember zwei Wochen hatten in
denen die Sonne nicht geschien hat und
der Wind nicht gewählt hat und ähm die
ähm der der Strom Mix in Deutschland
tief braun war also 50% an einigen in
einigen Stunden sogar mehr als 50%
kohleanteil damit ist ein E-Auto erstmal
definitiv nicht sauberer als ein Auto
mit Verbrennungsmotor wir wissen z.B
auch hat VW ja selbst berechnet vor
einigen Jahren das ein E-Golf
hunderttausend Kilometer fahren muss
bevor er ökologischer ist als ein Auto
mit Verbrennungsmotor so und dann hoffen
wir mal dass die Batterie bis dahin hält
und nicht ausgetauscht werden musste
dann sind wir wahrscheinlich bei 150
160.000 km also zu glauben dass ein Auto
automatisch umweltfreundlicher ist als
ein Verbrennungsmotor das muss sich
wirklich erst nach einer langen langen
Fahrzeit und Fahrtdauer herausstellen
und die Diskussion hat Lust muss man
sagen um den Klimawandel wird hier bei
uns in Deutschland ganz schön emotional
geführt während andere Länder
Kohlekraftwerke bauen verliehen wir uns
da manchmal auch in so einer
Emotionalität in dieser Diskussion die
Frage an Sie müssen wir da ist es unsere
Pflicht für dieses Ziel als
Vorreiterrolle dass wir voranschreiten
dass wir da auch eine Vorbildfunktion
für den Rest der Welt haben und glauben
Sie dass das dann auch überhaupt
aufgehen kann ja das ist auch wieder
sowas absolut deutsch ist dass
Deutschland immer ein Vorbild sein muss
ich weiß gar nicht wo das herkommt ein
Freund von mir meinte mal früher wollte
Deutschland die Welt erobern heute
möchte Deutschland die Welt belehren ja
und das so kommt mir das auch manchmal
vor und bei diesem Thema der das
Verbrennungsmotors der soll ja 25
abgeschafft werden das heißt es müssen
12 Jahre bin ich rechnen kann ich glaube
das stimmt das heißt die Politik weiß
jetzt schon wenn man das umrechnet sie
weiß jetzt schon was
Wissenschaft in zwölf Jahren zu machen
hat dass man auf diese Mutter Art
verzichten will und soll das weiß ich
jetzt schon also die weiß ich jetzt
schon offensichtlich dass der
Elektromotor auf jeden Fall durchgeht
vielleicht stimmt vielleicht stimmt's
nicht die Politik weiß jetzt schon dass
eflurs nicht marktfähig werden das weiß
ich alles jetzt schon ich finde das also
er hat schon eine gewisse ja wählerische
ja nach vorne gehende Atmosphäre wo ich
mir denke diesen Mut hätte ich nicht
also diese ähm ja diese diese kurzbezug
trauen aber die Worte der Politiker muss
man nicht über die goldware leben heute
sagen zu der Zeit sind sie nicht mehr am
Abend sind dafür nicht mehr
Verantwortlichen verlängert dazu also
deswegen schöne politische Phrasen die
besonders grünen ideologischen
Interessen folgen aber ich sehe in der
Umsetzung nicht ich hoffe kannst du
reden ja aber ich bezweifel ist dass es
wirklich dann dazu kommt vielleicht wenn
die klugen Köpfe und auf unserer Welt
wirklich da sind was da finden dann
freue ich mich darüber aber ich glaube
es auch nicht dass es wirklich natürlich
diese Frage wird dann ja auch sein wenn
wir alle auf E-Auto setzen als 2035 geht
ja erstmal nur für Neuwagen aber gibt es
eigentlich genug Strom der hergestellt
wird gibt es noch geladen ist das erste
aber das zweite ist da gibt's genug
Strom gibt Studien auch in Deutschland
die sagen wir werden in massives
Stromproblem laufen und beim Thema
Vorbild vollkommen richtig glaube ich
beim Thema Vorbild muss man sagen ist
der deutsche Weg ja schon ein ein
wirklicher Sonderweg in Europa wir
machen diese Energiewende seit mehr als
23 Jahren jetzt 98 unter Gerhard
Schröder rot grün angefangen also sind
im 25 Jahr und müssen feststellen es
gibt keinen großes Industrieland außer
Deutschland das komplett aus der
Kernkraft aussteigt auch aus der
Braunkohle und eigentlich zu aller aller
größten Teilen nur noch auf erneuerbare
Energien setzt weder die drei Länder vor
uns USA China und Japan noch hinter uns
Frankreich Großbritannien und ein paar
andere setzen oder nehmen die Kernkraft
raus keines egal das Gegenteil selbst in
Japan dem Land mit dem großen Erdbeben
und dem großen Atomunfall werden neue
Kernkraftwerke oder sollen neue
tischkraftwerke gebaut werden da müsste
sich glaube ich Deutschland Fragen
Stichwort Vorbild nach 25 Jahren warum
folgt uns eigentlich keiner sind wir
möglicherweise der Geisterfahrer
auf die nächste Ebene sie sehen hier in
dieser Runde da ist so verhaltener
Optimismus was das Thema angeht aber was
glauben Sie wie sehen sie Deutschland
sind über die Anpassung gesprochen in 10
in 20 in 50 Jahren wenn wir so weiter
also momentan sehe ich vor allem dass
wir so verschleierungsdiskussionen
führen ja wir reden darüber wir stellen
so rasch wie möglich die auf auf Autos
um und damit ist im Kopf abgehakt
psychologisch klimagerätet wir steigen
aus dem Kohle aus klimagerätet wir
steigen aus der Nuklearenergie raus wir
bauen überall erneuerbare könnten wir
jetzt verlängern die ganze Reihe das
sind Diskussion und dann gibt's die
moralische noch hier wir müssen
besonders viel tun weil wir ja in der
Vergangenheit als entwickelte Länder
besonders viel auch Schuld gehabt haben
ja da kommt dieses diese Liebe zur
deutschen Schuldiskussion heraus die
überhaupt nicht
irrelevant ist weil es vollkommen egal
ist wie wer wie viel CO2 in der
Vergangenheit ausgestoßen hat es kommt
nur darauf an wie viel wir heute
ausstoßen wie wir morgen ausstoßen was
wir machen müssen in Deutschland dann
haben wir diese Verzicht und
verbotsreligion es kommt Religion
in dem Moment schon an Protestantismus
das kommt schon von unserer
protestantischen Vergangenheit her ist
auch vollkommener Unsinn weil in was wir
uns verbieten und wir können ja nur uns
was verbieten vielleicht können wir in
der EU 550 Millionen Menschen was
verbieten ja aber wir können nicht 8
Milliarden was verbieten was wir uns
verbieten worauf wir verzichten ist von
der Auswirkung hier reicht gegen Null
was wir können und wohin wir
zurückkommen müssen damit ich durchaus
optimistisch wir müssen und das ist
unser asset unsere Technologie unsere
technologische Kompetenz einsetzen und
entwickeln und zwar völlig Ergebnis
offen ja es gibt leider leider so eine
Tendenz gerade bei den Grünen über so
technologieoffenheit zu verteufeln ja
das z.B Atom an Energie das ist abgehakt
darf es nie wiedergeben die
Brennstoffzelle abgehakt darf es nie
wiedergeben im Gegenteil ja die Welt
wird auf diese Herausforderung die so
massiv sind die so viel Opfer und so
viel Preise so viel Opfer hervorrufen
mit allem reagieren die Welt ja
möglicherweise wird deutsche nicht ja
aber da sind wir selbst schuld die Welt
wird die Kernfusion probieren die
Kernspaltung probieren den Salz und
Thorium Reaktion runtergehen die Welt ja
nur wir in auf unserer Insel wir
verlieren uns in diesen Schein und
schleierdiskussionen diskutieren Dinge
die überhaupt völlig irrelevant sind und
müssen endlich damit aufhören
noch muss man sagen ob absolut unehrlich
wenn man den Chef der Bundesnetzagentur
hört der in einer Beiratssitzung mit
Politikern dann sich freut dass die
französischen AKW wieder stärker am Netz
sind hier aber gleichzeitig in
Deutschland dafür mit trommelt erst
grünen Politiker und war früher mal
Umweltminister Schleswig-Holstein und
ist Robert habe ich unterstellt und sich
hier darüber freut dass wir aus der
Kernkraft aussteigen da muss man einfach
sagen das passt einfach nicht zusammen
gleiches Beispiel im Thema Tracking Gas
das holen wir uns rein sind aber gegen
das Tracking hier in Deutschland also es
passt überhaupt nicht zusammen das ist
wie glaube ich ganz gut festgestellt
haben man schiebt das Problem weg
um gleichzeitig einfach das saubere
Image zu haben wir haben die weiße Weste
bezieht aber diese angeblich so bösen
Energie und Energieträger oder
Energiequellen dann aus dem Ausland und
das ist natürlich total verlogen
wichtige Diskussionen die wir hier bei
8:15 Uhr auch weiter führen werden wo
wir ganz genau hinschauen wollen vielen
herzlichen Dank an meine Gäste und auch
ihnen vielen herzlichen Dank fürs
zuschauen heute bei 8:15 Uhr bis morgen
[Musik]